[Musik]
was liest du das architektur berater
neues wohnungsbauprojekt dem gebiet
eines ehemaligen tagebaus im ruhrgebiet
werden ökologische wohnungen für
verschiedene generationen gebaut
ich informiere mich darüber während des
industriellen zeitalters um 1800
entdeckte man im ruhrgebiet große
kohlevorkommen
seitdem wurde im ruhrgebiet unter
schweren arbeitsbedingungen viel bergbau
betrieben
die region hatte während des aufschwungs
fast sechs millionen einwohner
heute ist die nachfrage an braun und
steinkohle gesunken und deshalb werden
viele bergwerke geschlossen und die
frage ist was macht man mit ihnen
schrebergärten kann man nicht überall
bauen zufrieden
selma achte auf dahinter
du musst mich und deine vater verstehen
und wer versteht mich
hey ich brauche deine hilfe
liebe grüsse emma